you and your wife are very eco-friendly
which I admire mmm
does that ever get put right way cuz I
like to try and you know help the
environment but all of us find moments
in our life were like okay that's going
a little too far I draw the line
yes so we watched an episode of sixty
minutes about the plastics and it was
very disturbing
how much plastics and the ocean and the
rivers and everything the way I dealt
with that was I just made myself feel
guilty if I drank from a plastic water
container my wife actually took action
and she you know went too far I'd argue
she found toilet paper that doesn't come
in a big cellophane wrapping it comes in
like a brown old sack like burlap EE or
something yeah so she put it in all the
bathrooms it's the worst toilet paper
it's it's porta potti toilet paper so
wherever they get it is where my wife
started yeah yeah right so I was like
honey I love the environment I can't
possibly clean myself with that it's
like sandpaper
that's no I wish you were like sandpaper
I've never been sanding and my fingers
just popped through
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this this is the thickness of a gust of
wind yeah you know it's it's just wispy
thin as I'm pulling it off the roll my
fingers are going through it like well
I'm not gonna wanna gather all these
bits and put anyways you you get it you
get the pitch yeah yeah Nonie don't go
into that yeah I had to tell her I'm
like honey I love you I love our earth
I'm getting my own toilet paper and so I
put next to the toilet I've his toilet
paper lo and behold it's being used a
lot more than I'm using it you think
your wife yes defying dabbling in the
good toilet paper yeah yes so for looks
you know it looks like we have this
right you guys look like an eco couple
but really she's had a couple other
misfires as well she we for Christmas
this year or not we she bought these
like little reindeer statues that were
made of logs and unbeknownst to us I
guess our daughter had become attached
to one of these reindeers emotionally
like a toy or something yes that lived
on the porch
I don't know neither of us realized how
deep the connection was so we ran out of
firewood
[Applause]
and my wife said I'm gonna throw one of
those reindeer in the fire I said honey
I know I think those things are
slathered in flame retardant like you
know it'll probably poison that the
whole household she didn't listen she
put it in the firebox cranked up that
gas rod Ulsan Lincoln comes in sees her
friend in golf and Blackie
how old is Lincoln 6
her friend is on fire there's poison
just billowing out of the the fire place
and that was somehow recycling we have
we have a picture of what you have it
won't burn no you like burned it's
getting black but it's not it's her
laughing yes laughing my daughter yeah
your father killed me
[Laughter]